Selamlar 9. sınıf tayfam. Kanalıma hoş
geldiniz. Ben Deniz Hoca. Kısa bir ara
vermiştik çalışmalara. Sınavlar girdi
araya ve devamında ara tatili girdi ve
tekrar sizlerle çalışmamıza devam
ediyoruz. Neredeyiz şimdi? İkinci temaya
artık hoş geldin diyoruz. Hemen
kitabımızda sayfa 51'i açıyorsun. Orada
anlam arayışı temasını göreceksin ve
konuları göreceksin. Hikaye daha
sonrasında anı. Bunların özelliklerini
deneyeceğiz ve daha sonrasında
metinlerin sınıflandırmasına bakacağız
ve devamında da şiir üzerine birazcık
çalışıp bu ikinci temayı bitireceğiz.
Ama tabii ki yine ilk temada olduğu gibi
bolca etkinlik karşımıza çıkacak. Fakat
kitaptaki etkinlikleri yapabilmeniz için
bazı konuları bilmiş olmanız gerekiyor.
İşte ben de bu kitaptan ve bu videolarla
o konuları sana anlatacağım. Yani arka
planda kafanda herhangi bir soru işareti
kalmayacak. Evet, Maarif sınıfımız var.
Bundan da bahsetmek istiyorum. Sadece
biliyorsunuz edebiyat derslerini bu
maarif sınıfları kapsamında
anlatmıyoruz. Aynı zamanda şu anda da
ekranda gördüğünüz kıymetli hocalarımla
birlikte birçok derste sizlere yardımcı
olmaya çalışıyoruz. ücretsiz PDF'leri ve
bu kanalları videonun açıklamalar
kısmındaki WhatsApp kanalından
bulabilirsiniz. Mutlaka oraya da göz
atıyorsun. E öyleyse hazırsan bu videoyu
beğendiysen ilk konumuz olan hikaye
konusuna yakından göz atmaya başlayalım.
Klavyeyi de bayağı uzağa koymuşum.
Değiştirmek için eğilmek durumunda
kalıyorum. Neyse hikaye nedir? Şimdi
temel bir konu hikayeyi baştan sona
kadar her ayrıntısıyla ele alacağız ama
seni sıkmayacağım. Bilmen gereken
aslında öz bilgiler burada altı çizile
çizile her zaman olduğu gibi sana
aktarılmaya devam edilecek. Şimdi
hikayeye şöyle bir tanım yapabilir miyiz
ki hocanız soracaktır. Hikaye nedir diye
soracak. Sen de diyeceksin ki gerçek ya
da gerçeğe yakın olay ve durumların
okuyucuda heyecan ve zevk uyandıracak
şekilde kısa ve özlü biçimde anlatıldığı
edebi türe biz hikaye diyoruz. Hikayenin
tanımı genel anlamda böyle. Genellikle
hikayeler tek bir olay örgüsüne dayanır.
Mesela eğer roman olsaydı bu kadar kısa
ve öz olmayacaktı. Roman uzun olacaktı.
Fakat hikayelerde genellikle tek bir
olay anlatılır. Kişi sayısı sınırlıdır
ve tek bir olay üzerinden bu hikaye öz
bir şekilde bitirilir. Biz bu türe
hikaye diyoruz. Yani tek bir olay örgüsü
karşımıza çıkacak. Ama roman olsaydı
mesela daha uzun ve daha karmaşık olay
örgüleri olacaktı. Fakat hikayede biz bu
durumu görmüyoruz. Dolayısıyla tek bir
olay örgüsü, sınırlı bir mekan az sayıda
kişiye yer verir ve kahramanların
yalnızca bir yönü ön plana çıkarılır.
Fakat roman öyle değildir. Yani kahraman
50 sayfa boyunca bizlere aktarılabilir
romanda. Yani gerçekten bir karakterin
50 sayfa boyunca tanıtıldığını
görebiliyoruz. Ama hikayede böyle
değildir bu. Dolayısıyla 10 sayfada
ortalama hikaye biter. Dolayısıyla
yalnızca bir yönü ön plana çıkarılır
kahramanın. Zaman ve mekanda ayrıntıya
girilmez. Bu yönlerli hikaye diğer
anlatı türlerinden ayrılır. Daha kısadır
diyebiliriz. Peki hikayenin dünyadaki ve
edebiyatımızdaki gelişimi nasıl
olmuştur? Biraz bundan bahsedelim.
Arkadaşlar biz hikayenin ilk örneklerini
İtalyan'ın edebiyatında Cuvvan
Bakochaça'da görüyoruz. Onun yazmış
olduğu Decameron dünyada bilinen ilk
hikaye örnekleridir. Bu genel kültür
bakımından da her zaman aklında kalsın.
Ama bizim edebiyatımıza hikayenin ilk
örnekleri Tanzimat döneminde geliyor.
Çünkü Tanzimat döneminden önce tabii biz
daha çok Doğu edebiyatlarını örnek
alıyoruz. Arap edebiyatını, Fars
edebiyatını vesaire. Fakat Tanzimat
dönemi ile birlikte artık yüzümüzü
Avrupa'ya dönüyoruz. E Avrupa'da ne var?
Roman var. Ne var? Hikaye var. Ne var?
Tiyatro var. Ne var? Eleştiri var. Ne
var? Gazete var. Ne var? Dergi var. Ne
var? Gezi yazısı var. Ne var? Eleştiri
var. Deneme, makale, sohbet, fıkra.
Dolayısıyla bunları biz hep Tanzimat
döneminde alıyoruz. Dolayısıyla genel
anlamda aslında hani ezberlemeyin ya
Tanzimat bu dönemdi işte daha doğrusu
hikaye bu dönemde gelmişti. Roman bu
dönemde gelmişti. Hayır arkadaşlar
ilkler hep Tanzimat döneminde olmuştur.
Bunu unutmayacaksın. Ve bu dönemde Ahmet
Mitthat Efendi'in yazmış olduğu Letaifi
Rivayet adlı eser ilk hikaye örneği
olarak kabul edilir edebiyatımızda. Yani
aklınıza kim gelecek? Ahmet Mithat
Efendi gelecek. Onun letaif ve rivayet
adlı eseri hemen aklına gelmeli. Fakat
ilkler her zaman kusurludur.
Biliyorsunuz bir şeyler yapmaya
çalışmışız, örnekler vermeye çalışmışız
ama ya hikayeye benziyor ama tam olarak
hikaye değil. Kusurlar var. Dolayısıyla
bir de bu kusurlardan arındırılmış ilk
hikaye örneğimiz vardır. Onu da yazan
Sami Paşazade Sezai'dir. Önemlidir.
Aklınıza tutacaksınız. Yani diyeceğiz ki
batılı anlamdaki ilk modern hikaye Sami
Paşazade Sezai tarafından yazılmıştır.
Onun Küçükşeyler adlı eseri önemli. Ders
kitaplarında da ve hatta üniversite
sınavlarında da yine küçük şeylerden
karşımıza bölümler, kesitler çıkıyor. O
bakımdan dikkat edin. Peki Tanzimat'ten
önce hocam hikaye yok muydu?
Tanzimat'tan önce bugün bildiğimiz
hikaye yoktu. Roman yoktu. Fakat bizim
edebiyatımız zengin bir anlatı geleneği
barındırır. Yani evet hikaye yoktu,
roman yoktu. Fakat halkın hayal ve
tecrübelerini yansıtan destanlar,
masallar, halk hikayeleri, Mesneviler,
Dede Korkuk hikayeleri dolayısıyla bolca
hikayeye benzeyen anlatı türleri vardı.
Dolayısıyla bir şekilde karşılanıyordu
romanlar ve hikayeler. Mesela Divan
Edebiyatında Mesneviler vardı. Halk
edebiyatında destanlar, masallar, halk
hikayeleri, dedikort hikayeleri roman ve
hikayenin yerini tutuyordu. Dolayısıyla
biz Tanzimat döneminde aslında
hikayeleri gördüğümüzde, romanı
gördüğümüzde çok fazla şaşırmadık. Hemen
de adapte olduk. Neden? Çünkü zaten
bizde bir anlatı geleneği fazlasıyla
güçlüydü ve vardı. Devam edelim.
Biliyorsunuz Tanzmat'tan sonra Servet
Fonun geliyor. Sonra Milli Edebiyat
dönemi geliyor. Sonra Cumhuriyet
dönemleri geliyor. Bu dönemlerde hikaye
türünde önemli eserler veriliyor ve Türk
edebiyatındaki gelişimi sürüyor. Ama
şunu da söylemek gerekiyor tabii. Yani
bu genel bir bilgi. Aklınızda kalsın.
Tanzimat döneminde evet hikaye örnekleri
var. Sonra Tanzimat sonra Servet Fonun
geliyor. Orada da hikaye örnekleri var.
Fakat bu dönemde hikaye ayrı bir tür
olarak ele alınmıyor. Genellikle romanın
kısa hali olarak bakılıyor. Yani ben
hikayeciyim, senin yazdığın bu hikaye
türüdür şeklinde bir ayrım yapılmıyor.
Bu ayrım ne zaman yapılıyor biliyor
musunuz? Milli Edebiyat döneminde Ömer
Seyfettin'le birlikte gerçekleşiyor.
Artık Ömer Sefettin'in hikayeciliğini
biz şöyle alıyoruz. Ya o dönemde yani
Milli Edebiyat döneminde Ömer
Sefettin'in yazmış olduğu hikayelerle
şunu kanıtlıyor. Kardeşim hikaye ayrı
bir türdür ve hikayeci de romancıdan
ayrıdır. Bu mantığı yerleştiriyor. Bu
bakımdan Ömer Seyptin ve Milli Edebiyat
dönemi önemlidir. Şimdi hikayenin
bölümlerine göz atalım. Her anlatı
türünde olduğu gibi hikayede de üç ana
bölüm vardır. Yani bir hikaye şöyle
başlarsanız öncelikle olay, kişiler ve
mekan tanıtılır. Burası giriş bölümüdür.
Biz buna serim diyoruz. Yani olayları
şöyle sermeye başlarsın. Sonra olayları
düğümlersin. En heyecanlı olan yerdir
artık. Orada çatışma işlenir, merak
artar vesaire. Oraya biz düğüm bölümü
diyoruz. Ve 3üncü bölüm ise çözüm
bölümüdür. Burada artık olaylar bir
sonuca ulaştırılır. Yani düğüm çözülür,
merak edilenler cevaplanır. Bu şekilde
hikaye bitmiş olur. Bu romanda da
böyledir, unutma. Bu masalda da
böyledir. Tabii başında ve sonunda
ayrıca iki bölüm daha vardır. Daha
doğrusu birer bölüm vardır. Mesela
Fable'da da böyledir. Mesnede de
böyledir. Yani demek istiyorum ki ya sen
bir olay anlatıyorsan zaten giriş,
gelişme, sonuç yani serim, düğüm, çözüm
olmak durumunda ama bu türden türe
başına ve sonuna farklı bölümler
eklenebilir. Fakat standart üç tanedir.
Dolayısıyla roman ve hikayede serim
düğüm çözümü görüyoruz. Peki bir de
hikayenin yapı unsurları var. Bak bu da
önemli. Bunu hep aklına tut. Çünkü
aynısını biz roman için de söyleyeceğiz.
Aynısını bir mesnev için de
söyleyebiliriz, masa için de
söyleyebiliriz vesaire. Yani olay
anlatan metinlerde o metni oluşturan, o
türü oluşturan bazı yapı unsurları
vardır. Mesela bir ev temelsiz olmaz,
demirsiz olmaz, betonsuz olmaz. Ya bir
hikaye, bir roman da kesinlikle olay
olmadan olmaz. Kişi olmadan da olmaz,
mekan olmadan da olmaz, zaman olmadan da
olmaz. Dolayısıyla bir hikaye hikaye
yapan unsurlar olaydır, kişidir,
mekandır, zamandır. Dolayısıyla bu dört
tane yapı unsurunu aklında tutacaksın.
Olay nedir? Kahramanların başından geçen
durumların olay örgüsü halinde
aktarılmasıdır. Ana olaya bağlı tabii
küçük olaylar vardır. Bunlar birbirine
zincir gibi bağlıdır ve olay örgüsü
ortaya çıkar. Kişi bu olayın merkezinde
yer alan kahramanlardır. Biz bunlara
kişiler diyoruz. Mekan ise olayın
geçtiği, genellikle sınırlı sayıda
tutulan yerdir. Zaman ise olayın
yaşandığı dönem, mevsim, gün ya da andır
ya da süredir. Olayın gerçekleşmesi
süreci yine ya da daha doğrusu süresi
diyelim. bu zamanı oluşturur. Bunun
dışında anlatıcının bakış açıları
vardır. Yani bu olay hangi bakış açısı
anlatılmış? Bunu bir sonraki derste daha
ayrıntılı ele alacağım. Ama burada özet
bilgisi var. Göz atabilirsiniz. Ama
ikinci videomuz bununla ilgili olacak.
Daha detaylı bilgi içerecek. Bunu da
söyleyeyim. Şimdi gelelim hikayenin
diğer unsurlarına. Burada da bir tema
karşımıza çıkıyor. Tema nedir? Hikayede
üzerinde durulan temel duygu ve
düşüncedir. Soyut ve genel bir kavramı
ifade eder. Mesela roman ya da hikaye
okudun. Orada aşk, dostluk, özlem,
özgürlük temayı oluşturabilir. Konu ise
bu temanın somutlaştırılmış ve
sınırlandırılmış halidir. Evet. Aşkı
okudun ama kimin aşkı? İşte dostluğu
okudun ama kimin dostluğu? İşte özgürlük
ama kimin özgürlüğü? Mesela bir ülkenin
özgürlüğü mü? Yoksa bir kişinin
özgürlüğü mü? Bu değişir. İşte bunun
sınırlandırılmış haline biz ne diyoruz?
Konu diyoruz. Mesela hep şiirden örnek
veriyorum. Diyorum ki, "Leyla ve
Mecnudun şiirini okudun ya da hikayesini
okudun." Hatta hikaye olarak bakalım.
Oradaki aşk evet temayı oluşturur. Peki
kimin aşkı? Onu daha da somutlaştırmanız
ve özele indirgemeniz gerekiyor. İşte
orada Leyla ve Mecnun çıkıyor. O da
konuyu oluşturuyor. Ya da İstiklal
Marşı'dan bakalım. İşte baktığımız zaman
tema nedir? Vatan aşkıdır.
Bağımsızlıktır. Fakat onu daha da
sınırlandırırsak, somut hale getirirsek
kimin vatan aşkı? Kimin bağımsızlığı?
Türk milletinin bağımsızlığı, Türk
milletinin vatan aşkı ve mücadelesi
konuyu oluşturur. Aynısını burada da
düşüneceksiniz. Yani bir aşk var. Evet o
temadır. Ama Ahmet'le Ayşe'nin aşkı o
neyi oluşturur? Konuyu oluşturur. Bir de
çatışma vardır. Bak bu da önemli.
genellikle kafamızı karıştırıyor bu
çatışma bölümü hikayenin temelini
oluşturan olay örgüsünü ileriye taşıyan
gerilim ve mücadeledir. Şimdi çatışma
kavramını sürekli duyacaksınız. Romanda
duyacaksınız, tiyatroda duyacaksınız
vesaire. Sakın ha aklınıza kavga dövüş
gelmesin. Çünkü çatışma demek hikayede
ya da romanda kavga dövüş değildir. O
hikayeyi hikaye yapan, o romanı roman
yapan olayın içindeki zıtlıktır aslında.
Yani gerilim ve mücadele biz çatışma
diyoruz. Yani çatışma, kahramanların
karşılaştığı engeller, sorunlar, işsel
ikilemler olarak ortaya çıkar. Ve tabii
çatışma varsa hikaye olur. Çatışma yoksa
oradaki zıtlık yoksa, mücadele yoksa
neyi anlatacaksın? Neyi anlatmaya değer
göreceksin? Tabii bunu yapamazsın.
Dolayısıyla hikaye sürekliyici, dinamik
ve ilgi çekici kılan unsur çatışmadır.
Mesela bir örnek verelim. Bir öğrencinin
ailesinin beklentileriyle kendi
hayalleri arasındaki durum bir
çatışmadır. Unutma bu çatışmayı
oluşturur. Mesela bir öğrenci var.
Hayali doktor olmak olsun ama ailesi
onun mühendis olmasını istiyor. E o da
mücadele ediyor. Ailesiyle mücadele
ediyor. Hayalleriyle mücadele ediyor.
İşte mühendis olmak istemiyor. Doktor
olmak istiyor. İşte onun hikayesini
okuyoruz. Onun hayatını okuyoruz.
Oradaki çatışma nedir? İşte çocuğun
kendi beklentisiyle ailesinin beklentisi
arasında mücadele etmesi, bunun arasında
kalması oradaki çatışmadır. Burada bir
kavga, bir dövüş var mı? Yok. Orada bir
zıtlık vardır. Değil mi? Bir aslında bir
ikilem vardır. İşte bu da çatışmayı
oluşturur. Çatışma budur. Bir örnek
olsun diye çatışma örneği getirdim.
Hemen okuyalım. Genç ve yetenekli bir
ressam olan Elif, yıllardır üzerinde
çalıştığı büyük sergisinin açılışına
hazırlanmaktadır. Resimleri, ışık ve
gölge oyunlarıyla dolu derin anlamlar
içeren eserlerdir. Ancak son tablosunu
bir türlü tamamlayamaz. Sanki Tuval'de
eksik bir şeyler vardır. İlhamını bulmak
için çocukluğunu geçirdiği kasabaya geri
döner. Kasabada yıllar önce terk edilmiş
eski bir konak keşfeder. Konağın
duvarlarındaki silik freksler ve
odalardaki antikaşalar Elif'e ilham
verir. Ancak konak kasabanın zengin iş
insanı Tarık Bey tarafından yıkılıp
yerine alışveriş merkezi yapılmak üzere
satın alınmıştır. Elif Konağın tarihi ve
sanatsal değerini korumak isterken Tarık
Bey ise modernleşme ve kar amacıyla
yıkımı hızlandırmak istemektedir. Elif
konağı korumak için kasaba halkını
bilinçlendirmeye çalışır. İmza
kampanyaları düzenler ve yerel yönetimle
görüşür. Tarık Bey ise etkisini
kullanarak Elif'in çabalarını boşa
çıkarmaya çalışır. İkisi arasında hem
kişisel hem de ideolojik bir çatışma
başlar. Sonunda Elif son tablosunu bu
çatışmadan doğan duygularla tamamlar ve
sergisine büyük bir başarı elde eder.
Tablosu konağın ve kasabanın ruhunu
yansıtarak insanlara dokunur. Bu başarı
kasaba halkının konağan değerini
anlamasına yardımcı olur ve konağın
yıkımını durdurur diyor ya da
durdurulur. Şimdi buradaki çalışmalar
nedir? Şimdi hikaye hikaye yapan bazı
böyle zıtlıklar vardır. Mesela burada
birey ve güçlü bir otorite çatışması yok
mudur? Mesela Elif'in sanatını ve tarih
mirasını koruma isteğiyle zengin bir iş
adamı olan, gücü olan Tarık Bey'in maddi
kazanç ve modernleşme hedefleri
arasındaki mücadele mesela buradaki
çatışmadır. Bunun dışında gelenek ve
modernlik mesela eski olanak koruma
çabası var. Eski olanı koruma çabası
aynı zamanda yeni olanı inşa etme isteği
vardır para kazanmak için. Mesela bunun
arasında da bir çatışma vardır. Bununla
birlikte idealizm ve realizm vardır.
Yani Elif'in idealleri vardır. Sanatsal
bakışı vardır. Bununla birlikte Tarık
Bey'in gerçekçi ve pragmatik yaklaşımı
vardır. Çünkü para kazanması lazım. İşte
bunlar çatışma olarak karşımıza çıkar ve
hikayenin ana temasını oluşturur ve
karakterlerin gelişimini yönlendirir
diyebiliriz. İşte çatışma örneğiydi. Üç
tane buradan çatışma örneği çıkardık.
Güzel bir örnek oldu açıkçası.
Dolayısıyla çatışmanın mantığını da
anlamış olduk. Hikaye ile ilgili
söyleyeceklerim bunlar. Aslında bunlar
öz bilgidir. Yani hikaye özetle neydi?
Olayların ya da durumların,
yaşanabilecek olayların, durumların ya
da yaşanmış olayların ve durumların
kişilerde estetik bir zevk oluşturacak
şekilde kısaca anlatıldığı bir edebi
türdür. Dolayısıyla hikaye hikaye yapan
unsurlar vardır. O da olay, kişi, zaman,
mekandı. Aynı zamanda hikayenin serim,
düğüm, çözüm bölümleri vardı. Aynı
zamanda bir hikayenin bakış açıları
vardır. Sonuç itibariyle mesela ben bir
hikaye yazdım. O hikayeyi size anlatan
birisi vardır. Onu ben anlatmıyorum
aslında. Ben bu hikayeyi yazarken,
kurgularken bir anlatıcı da
kurguluyorum. O anlatıcı olayları sana
anlatıyor. Dolayısıyla anlatıcı da
önemlidir. Ama bu anlatıcı olayı üç
farklı şekilde sizlere aktarabilir. Bir,
kahraman bakış açısıyla yani olayın
merkezinde yer alır ve gördüğü olayları,
daha doğrusu yaşadığı olayları kendi
ağzıyla anlatır. Yani ben ağzıyla bir
anlatım varsa mesela o an kalbim deli
gibi çarpıyordu. Bak benim kalbim ne
yapacağımı bilmiyordum diyorsa bu
kahraman bakış açısıdır. Bu birinci
seçenek. İkincisi gözlemci yani
kameraman bakış açısıdır. Olayı
dışarıdan görür, izler ve bir kameraman
gibi olayı size aktarır ve bunu 3üncü
ağızla yapar. Mesela o diliyle yapar. O
şöyle yaptı, böyle yaptı. Bak dışarı
çıktı vesaire. Bir de hakim tanrısal
ilahi bakış açısı vardır. Yani yine
gözlemci gibi dışarıdan görür. O ağzıyla
üçüncü ağızla anlatır. Fakat bu sefer
her şeyi bilir. Mesela kahramanın
içinden geçenleri bilir. Duygusunu
bilir. Psikolojik durumunu bilir. O an
ne düşünüyorsa onu da okuyucu aktarır.
Bu da ne olur? hakim bakış açısı olur.
Mesela adam gülümserken içinden derin
bir acı duyuyor, başına gelecekleri
bilmeden umutla yürüyordu. Mesela ne
yaptı? Kahramanın iç dünyasını bizlere
aktarmış oldu. Dolayısıyla bu da hakim
yani tanrısal ilahi bakış açısı. Çünkü
yani bazı tanrısal ilahi güçlere sahip
olman gerekiyor ki karmanın duygularını,
düşüncelerini, hislerini o an aklından
geçenleri bize aktarabilsin. Dolayısıyla
oradan da anlayabiliriz. Dolaysa demek
ki olaylar bir anlatıcı tarafından üç
farklı bakış açısıyla anlatılabilir.
Ağır basan unsur hangisiyse sen onu
bulup yazmalısın. Bunu ayrıca ben bundan
sonraki videoda daha da detaylı ve
örneklerle ele alacağım. O videoyu
seyretmeni tavsiye ediyorum diyorum. Ve
şimdilik burada dersimiz bitti. Hikayeyi
öz bir şekilde ele aldık. Bunlar sana
fazlasıyla yeterli olacaktır. 11'de de
10'da da 12. sınıfta da bu bilgileri
kullanabileceksin. Video ile ilgili,
dersle ilgili lütfen düşüncelerinizi
yorum kısmında paylaşmayı unutma. Aynı
zamanda bu videoyu beğenirseniz,
kanalıma abone olursanız Deniz hocanızı
desteklemiş olursunuz. Çünkü 1 milyona
doğru gidiyorum. Bu noktada senden
desteklerini bekliyorum. Öyleyse kendine
iyi bak. Hoşça kal. Sevgil.